we're hearing more stories of bravery
and hope after this massacre
Michael castor is one of the wounded he
says that he owes his life to his
girlfriend who made sure he was carried
to a stranger's car and taken very
quickly to a hospital Adriana Diaz spoke
with him last night she's outside
Sunrise Hospital in Las Vegas where a
caster and others are recovering Adriana
good morning good morning the sense of
grief is still so strong here but so is
the sense of gratitude among those who
came so close to death and survived we
spoke to Michael pastor and his
girlfriend in his hospital room both are
still coming to grips with what happened
Sunday night I was on the ground I
couldn't move I had no feeling from the
torso down shortly after this photo was
taken
41 year old Michael castor was shot
through his lung the bullet hitting his
spine just missing his heart his
girlfriend tawny found a table to use as
a gurney and others helped her carry him
to a stranger's car people were telling
me just leave they'll come back for the
survivors and I was like a motley man by
the time you thought well my my lungs
are already full
that's blood castor is one of hundreds
of shooting victims who survived
Sunday's rampage 27 year old Tina Frost
is in a coma and currently on a
respirator Mary is Tina's mother the
bullet went into her right eye
but there was no brain swelling which is
very good
there is only heartbreak for the
families who lost loved ones rocío Kia
leaves behind four children the youngest
born six weeks ago Chris her 13 year old
loved seeing his mom at his football
games I'm not gonna be able to get her
in the crowd again and like that's my
last memory of her I don't like Jeremy
on Steven Berger had come to Las Vegas
from Minnesota to celebrate his 44th
birthday hairdresser Stacy etching bear
was a mother of two and Heather Alvarado
ran a daycare center in Utah Michael
castor says he too might have died if
his girlfriend hadn't gotten him to the
hospital so quickly Mike if Tonya wasn't
there well I did take a bullet for her
so she was she was a penny back no I
don't know you know I may have not made
it part of casters lung has been removed
and he faces a long road to recovery but
he says doctors told him that was time
and physical therapy he will be able to
walk again he and his family are looking
for any alternative or experimental
treatments that could help viana
hopefully a good prognosis for him
Adriana but as you mentioned the victims
even a six week old is going to have to
learn about her how her mother died
thank you so much for that report